hey this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips and this is a level
130 candy crush soda walkthrough
tutorial with some commentary so this is
a tough level and the second room is the
real hard one so in this first room what
I'm trying to do is work on getting some
cascades happening because I have to get
eight bears in this room and the last
ones at the bottom so I want to get as
much stuff falling down as I can now
fish you know you're gonna make them
especially in the beginning because of
the space but really every day
everything else will be better like here
you can see with these wrapped candies
you know I get a much better cascade and
even here you know you might think all
oh I'm gonna lose the color bomb but at
the same time we have exactly what we
want going on we have the pieces
cascading down and that's given us more
more stuff so here we'll make this wrap
cluster it well it went off and we're
gonna lose that color in candy too but
again see how the pieces are cascading
now now what we want to do is try to get
out of here with about 23 maybe 25 moves
oh wait hold on a second that's getting
ready to make that color bomb and the
room the recorder glitched out a little
bit so it'll pop back up in a second so
yeah like so what I said is we're gonna
get out of here with about 25 news 23 is
good 2 below that it gets really tough
so a lot of times when I get down to
like 20 or around there I'll just quit
and restart because the second room
there's more bears it's it's okay here
we go so the color candy made that and
we'll definitely match this because this
is a really good combo for this board
because of the cascading and yeah so
when you have when you don't have very
many moves left I find that a lot easier
to just start over because it saved me
from getting
frustrated right now we have five bears
and we can see where the three are if we
made these two fish and if we would have
made the two fish they're meshing
together that would have been okay but
these two at the top still have had
double layers at the time so that's why
I just went for another cascade same
thing here and now we're down to one and
he just has one layer so we can make
either match here we can make the
coloring kit are the wrapped candy here
that's gonna hit that or we can just set
off this fish over here and then I'll go
there because remember fish always go
towards where the Bears are on honey
levels whenever there's bears around so
the second half we got our eight bears
and we still have 12 more and this is
why you really need to have a moose
because this is harder part of it is
because it's upside down that's a little
bit harder to concentrate at least for
me I don't know if other people have
that problem but you know I can get if
there's a flipped over I just feel like
it would be easier for me for some
reason so we're gonna want to make it
special as obviously combos like this
one are great and since we have we got
it through here with 26 moves so that
was pretty good so we have a little bit
of play but you have to really plan
things out anyways because those last
bears are down at the bottom with all
those layers on them so we're gonna try
to set up some you know some color
bottom or color caning combos that we
can there is one color bomb in the
middle here below this bear right in
front of us and that can be really good
if you can get another you know another
special down there once you get it
covered up so we have a lot of choices
you know I said definitely take your
time like here I'm gonna make the color
bomb anyways but I'll make the fish
first so that I can get this because
this will send fish to all the I'll take
a layer off all the Bears and you can
see where some of them are I mean
they're just buried in there
and you know this level used to have ten
more moves and I thought it was pretty
difficult at that point still and they
changed it to make it harder and they
never changed it back so I know exactly
how you feel I mean I play this a couple
times I think this is the third time now
and I didn't even really come close on
the first two I got the first room with
20 moves the first time and it's
something like eighteen two didn't
really have a chance hopefully you can
make the best out of this one because
there it's just they're rare you know
getting a good a good set up in the
second room it just doesn't happen that
often so here I think we just make
another striped and that'll set off one
and set off the fish and it's the same
concept of wanting to have the Cascade
happen and if we can it's not always
gonna work great but now you can see
we're down to four bears and we have 11
moves and that sounds great but we're
pretty stuck at this point so hopefully
we can get a decent combo because every
single one of these 11 moves is gonna
it's gonna count and I am thinking about
the fact that I have this coloring this
color bomb right inside here and it
would probably be helpful to get that
freed up it's right here in front of me
right now my probe this yellow one but
there's still a couple layers on there
so look over the board down here I see I
have a collar bomb and definitely make
that and this is um this is something I
started to think about this luck point
is that sometimes just firing this color
color bomb off by itself might be better
if I can't set up a combo go with it
so here ideally I want to make a combo
but I only have six moves left so I
don't want to waste you know if I can
move some colors out of the way that I
need or you know hit a square that I
need by using it just as a color bomb
then that will look that'll be the best
thing to do
and you can also see I'm being really
calm I'm being really conscious of
what's next to them and I'm now that I
can see that color ball I'm going to try
to go ahead and match them together all
right so this only takes one layer off
but there's a little also clear the
board and we'll get some Cascade for
sure and you know it's sent out that and
I believe now if we just hit this it
will it'll set off that stripe inside
and we'll finish the level and it worked
so you know it definitely takes a good
board to get through here it's strange
because it takes a good board in the
first room so you have enough moves and
then you really have to be tactical in
the second room and just take your time
I had a real hard time beating this
whenever they change the number of moves
so I know that it's not easy and just
use this as an example keep these tips
in mind and you'll get past it
eventually please like the video if you
found it helpful share it with your
friends subscribe to our youtube channel
because what you said you put out a new
help videos like this all the time and
we would love to have you as a
subscriber
thanks